[Music]
this morning our series we call it short
supplies looking at how supply chain
problems could cause big chaos for
holiday shoppers nobody wants that
november is traditionally one of the
best months to find the deals but many
hot products are in short supply that's
why we're calling this short supply or
more expensive than usual consumer
reports reviews popular products
everything from headphones to kitchen
equipment and tracks the prices
throughout the year and they're finding
that while the sales might be starting
sooner we may not see the steep
discounts for black friday this year so
consumer report shopping editor that's
mary beth quirk looking like jessica
chastain for bryce dallas howard
joins us what you need to buy now in
order to get gifts in time for the
holidays good morning to you mary beth
good morning everyone good morning
everyone so people are thinking what do
i need to buy now we've been talking
about this story for the last couple
weeks you better get it you better get
it hurry up hurry up you're not going to
be able to get what you want so what's
your advice what do you think we need to
buy right now so the things right now
are those high-tech electronics anything
from laptops and smartphones and those
new game consoles that everybody wants i
know i had a friend trying to get a ps5
those you want to buy now because the
microchip shortage is affecting that and
also they're so in demand there's
probably not going to be sales on them
later anyway so buy them now if you see
them
even things like toys some popular kids
toys i'm sure parents get annoyed with
all those flashing lights and sounds but
if they have their heart set on
something
you want to pre-order it right now if
it's not available and if it is you
might want to think about buying it
right now because again it's not going
to go on sale everybody wants it it is
funny what you say about flashing toys
with lights because before i had kids i
thought it was great to give a gift
where they make noise once you have kids
you're like please don't give us
anything that makes noise but when you
talk about things being in short supply
does that mean we will not be able to
get deals you'll still be able to get
deals but again the things that are new
that everybody wants there's no reason
to discount those so you might want to
look for things like an older model a
previous model if you don't need like
all of the bells and whistles maybe you
need a little something you know not as
much of like a gaming graphic on your
laptop then you can find you can still
find deals on that people who are trying
to budget this out and want to wait uh
are there items where you could say
confidently yeah you can wait on that
yeah i think a lot of things like
cookware um apparel things that don't
require as much tech or you know
obviously shopping local things that you
can buy nearby
you can buy those now and or excuse me
you could buy those later those will
probably still go on sale things like
you know we always see the instant pot
those multi-cookers those kitchen
gadgets i think some of those things you
could wait on and definitely get some
good deals even tvs yeah when it comes
to black friday and cyber monday there's
two ways to look at it it's either i
can't wait yeah or
darn it i missed it right um how will
black friday and cyber monday compare to
previous years so they there will be
fewer discounts and they again might not
be as like door-busting shocking steep
discounts you know a 19 tv which you
should not buy 19 tv if you see one
anywhere tell the college student yes so
it's hard to buy a 19 team i mean you
probably you shouldn't just because it's
the cheapest does it mean perfect for
the dorm though consumer reports knows
i've used consumer reports for every tv
every appliance every washer dryer the
stove like it's amazing spot-on yeah so
we like to hear that so there will still
be deals but i mean and again it's hard
i wish i had a crystal ball and i could
say wait for this to drop exactly then
um but there will be deals and what
might happen is with some of those hot
in demand things if you don't get a deal
it might get a restock on that black
friday so if you're looking for that
video game console it's still good to
shop then because it might become
available so we've been telling people
uh they may want to buy their
thanksgiving food early so i guess that
means you can't really wait on the stove
either you got to get but so large
appliances the category of like big
things right what do you recommend so
the bigger the thing is the harder it is
to ship and to get here and that's
something that's really since the
pandemic has been affecting
large appliances so kind of that rule if
it ain't broke don't fix it right now if
you've got a working oven or a stove or
refrigerator make sure it's all tuned up
so it's ready or you've got a neighbor
you can use their oven if yours goes to
put on thanksgiving um but with those
you might want to wait six months if you
can or again you just might not be able
to get the exact right model that you're
looking at today but if you're willing
to compromise or check out cr.org for
our reviews of similar things you know
you can find you can find something
online shopping we know is big but you
say that there are benefits to actually
going into a store sure if you feel
comfortable um a lot of times again
there's no shipping delay when you're
walking out with it in your hands or
putting it in your car there's the
social aspect of getting together with
everybody but for the most part there
are going to be the same kinds of sales
online in stores most retailers are
doing both because they know people just
want to be able to decide so again you
can walk out with the product i'll
borrow that pin real quick because i
tell the wife if it's working don't
replace it
the good rule of life i think thank you
it's already on the curve it's already
on the curve it's been picked up nate
sometimes you want a new thing even
though it's working oh trust me gail i
know yes you think i got so many jobs
exactly i like how your wife thinks mary
beth quirk thank you so much thanks for
having me thank you really appreciate it